The SCP Foundation has a long history of experience
with humanoid anomalies, from simple reality
benders like SCP-239 to strange transplants
from other universes like SCP-2273.
But one of the oldest, strangest, and most
lethal humanoid anomalies in the Foundation’s
considerable cabinet isn’t a superhuman
or a soldier - it’s a man known only as
“Herr Chirurg”.
On first glance, SCP-542’s containment protocol
is seemingly standard - he is allowed to request
personal items and furniture for his cell,
so long as they are blunt and cannot be used
to cut skin.
Reasonable enough, and many such requests
have been granted.
The ones denied include nail files, clippers,
and a surgery kit which has been set aside
for testing only.
But continuing, SCP-542 requires some special
attention too.
A blood transfusion every week on request,
and even an organ transplant conducted by
Foundation doctors should any of his own organs
begin to fail.
SCP-542 offers to do the surgery himself,
but is repeatedly denied.
To understand the story of Herr Chirurg, we
must look back through time to several years
before SCP-542’s containment.
Over the past three years, there have been
a violent string of murders across America,
England, and Germany.
INTERPOL and the FBI are stumped, not only
by the wide range of attacks - anywhere from
forty-five to sixty murders across three countries
- but by the brutal nature of the attacks.
The victims were found in various states of
disassembly, body parts missing and tissue
removed.
They set up crime scenes and conducted complex
investigations, but they were simply unable
to find their man.
In one month, four people in Germany were
assaulted, with the muscle, tissue, and bone
removed from all of their limbs.
Three of them died from their injuries before
help could arrive, and the fourth was an American
woman staying at a shady German hotel.
The only reason she narrowly survived the
horrific attack was because of the actions
of her neighbor, a Foundation agent passing
through town.
He heard sounds of fighting in the room next
door at three in the morning, and broke the
door down to help, unaware of the horrific
scene he would find: a huge, misshapen man,
best-described as a “Frankenstein’s monster”.
His skin was a patchwork of different shades
stitched and grafted together, his chest was
sunken in, his arms were grotesquely long
for his body and his face was skeletal and
gaunt.
This creature, that would come to be named
SCP-542, was hunched over the fully-conscious
woman, vivisecting her leg to remove the sinew
and bone.
In shock, the agent pulled his weapon and
fired at the creature, which escaped through
the window unharmed.
The authorities were called and the woman
survived, although without her right leg.
Just before being amnesticized, the woman
provided a statement to the Foundation:
She had been staying in Germany for a few
days when she saw a strange man on her usual
bus one day.
Even though it was summer, the man was draped
and wrapped in layers of heavy coats, jackets
and a hat.
Though his face completely obscured, the woman
could tell he was staring at her from the
back of the bus.
Thinking it was just some creep, she ignored
him and got off at her stop.
For three days, she continued to take the
bus and ignore the strange man sitting in
the back.
Then, on the fourth day, when she got off
the bus that night and went to her hotel room,
she found the window open and the lights off,
and assumed she had been burglarized.
But as soon as she opened the door, she realized
she wasn’t alone.
Two freakishly long arms with disjointed hands
grabbed her ankles from under the bed and
brought her crashing to the floor.
Before she knew what was happening, she was
tied to the bed, and the hulking hunchback
was retrieving a surgical set and sharpening
his knives and tools.
Fearing the worst, she began to scream, and
the Agent heard her - but by the time he broke
in and shot his weapon, the creature had already
done too much damage to her leg.
The victim was amnesticized and told her leg
had been amputated in a car crash.
The Foundation took over the investigation
from Interpol, realizing this wasn’t some
regular serial killer - this was a creature,
a predator.
And to find it, they had to hunt SCP-542 like
After a long tracking and manhunt across Europe,
SCP-542 was brought into Foundation custody,
and research into this creature could begin.
The researchers were expecting an animal or
monster, something they could study and dissect.
Which is why they were so shocked when the
monster began speaking in tongues - German,
French, Polish, before settling on English,
all in a sharp German accent.
The beast was introducing itself – “Herr
Chirurg”, German for “Mister Surgeon”.
Preliminary investigations revealed much about
SCP-542, and confirmed the agent’s initial
impression was correct.
Herr Chirurg is a modern Frankenstein’s
monster.
His anatomy has been warped and malformed
- as the agent observed, his skin is a patchwork
of large chunks of skin grafted or sewn to
each other, no two of which seem to come from
the same person.
His ribcage is warped and twisted with all
the ribs jutting out in different directions,
and both his arms are different sizes - though
both are incredibly muscular and far too long
for his body.
Attached to each is a hand, but filled with
far more joints than any normal hand, allowing
him to bend his fingers in almost any direction.
His spine is hunched and twisted like a snake,
and the skin stretched tight over his skull
reveals a sunken cranium and a mouth with
far, far too many teeth - none of them from
the same source, and not all of them human.
And these are all simply the externally obvious
and most grotesque modifications.
Foundation staff have conducted intense medical
research, ranging from X-rays to comprehensive
DNA testing.
SCP-542’s bone and muscle structures are
asymmetrical, revealing the left and right
sides of his body come from different sources.
In fact, they reveal that almost all of his
organs and body parts have been replaced with
other body parts from different sources.
His DNA is heavily fragmented beyond all logic
- by any reasonable measure, SCP-542 should
have died a long time ago.
Instead, he is able to accept many blood types
and organ transplants without so much as discomfort,
much less the serious autoimmune response
that any normal person would get.
Not to mention, he is able to stay perfectly
aware even while performing complex brain
surgery on himself.
Herr Chirurg’s history is as enigmatic and
mysterious as the question of how he remains
alive.
He claims he was once a simple doctor from
Germany, ‘dreadfully normal’ until the
Great War began.
The Foundation has deduced this to mean that
he began his modifications to his body between
the World Wars, but it appears Herr Chirug
wasn’t just a monster on the outside; he
claims to have worked for the Nazis in World
War 2 as they conducted brutal human experimentation,
which he described as ‘boring’.
The exact nature and timeline of how he modified
himself without dying at some point is similarly
mysterious - he professes that he didn’t
work alone.
For more complex surgeries, such as implanting
his second heart or replacing parts of his
spinal cord, he had a team of ‘helpers’.
Who and where these surgical assistants are
now is a mystery – if they’re even alive.
After all, the Foundation has ample evidence
Herr Chirurg is able and willing to kill people
for their parts.
After all this exhaustive research on SCP-542,
you’d be forgiven for thinking that he is
some kind of mad scientist, driven insane
by his experimentation on his own body.
While no one can answer why Chirurg kills
except himself, he is almost frighteningly
sane.
This hulking monstrosity enjoys reading his
anatomy textbooks, which he requests on a
regular basis, along with filling out crossword
puzzles in German.
He’s friendly, too - described as ‘surprisingly
pleasant’ by the research team.
He holds long, intellectual conversations
on topics ranging from science and biology
in medicine to politics and history, which
he seems to recount with startling accuracy.
In fact, tissue testing has failed to return
a definitive age for the Surgeon.
He’s incredibly skilled at the game of chess,
and the research team is allowed to play with
him as a method of interview.
SCP-542 displays fluency in a variety of European
languages, though he prefers his supposedly
native German.
At first, the research team was enthused with
his presence, even if he was a little terrifying
- having a brilliant doctor to converse with
was a great distraction for them.
His ability to heal from intense surgery with
almost no organ rejection or allergic reactions
was considered a medical miracle, and rather
than locking him up and throwing away the
key, the research team decided to use him
to try and harness this incredible power for
modern medicine.
His books and notes, captured along with him,
reveal surgical techniques and methods far
more advanced than considered possible when
they were written.
For his part, SCP-542 was happy to comply
- he enjoyed performing surgery on himself
with an audience, using himself as a living
cadaver to explain his manner of surgery and
the functions of the body.
Unfortunately, observing him this close carried
a risk none of the researchers realized until
it was too late.
You see, Herr Chirurg isn’t just a friendly
old surgeon.
His body runs off second-hand parts, and is
constantly failing.
Organs stop functioning, blood flow ceases,
parts of his body grow gangrenous and necrotic.
SCP-542 is able to anomalously detect when
this is happening - he is perfectly and acutely
aware of his own body functions like digestion
and peristalsis.
And he knows exactly when one of his organs
is starting to give up or his flesh is beginning
to decay.
When this happens, the Surgeon undergoes a
drastic transformation.
His pleasant exterior evaporates.
He grows moody and withdrawn, snapping at
people and avoiding conversation.
He spends long periods of time observing people,
using his ability to sense how well their
body is.
And then, when he senses an opening, he strikes.
Just like his murders in Europe, he picks
the body of his victims clean of the body
parts he needs and lets them die of blood
loss.
Then he performs the surgery to replace his
own failing organs with the new ones, and
returns to his usual demeanor.
This monstrous Jekyll-Hyde relationship isn’t
purely need-based, either.
The research team has discovered that Herr
Chirurg will also dissect people simply for
the joy of the act.
In one regrettable incident, a sewing kit
was left behind in his cell.
Several hours later, guards discovered a D-class
sewn to the mattress in SCP-542’s cell,
with the Surgeon carefully and gleefully extracting
his organs.
SCP-542, “Herr Chirurg”, is a walking
encyclopedia of medical and surgical knowledge.
But all that knowledge comes from experimentation
on himself and on unwilling victims - the
Foundation has put him to use in certain projects,
but all activity with him is to be strictly
monitored and regulated.
Despite appearances, SCP-542 isn’t a person
- he’s a predator and an exceptionally skilled
and dangerous one at that.
One moment of inattentiveness can result in
a fate much worse than death around him - but
you can rest assured that if something does
happen, your parts won’t go to waste.
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured (SCP Animation & Story)” and “SCP
Immortal Dr. Bright Explained (SCP Animation)
for more Anomalous SCP Doctors!